every now and again something happens on
mainstream media that allows you to see
through the veil there is a woman who
has been guest hosting on the program
known as the view which is where five
generally crazy women who used to not be
insane sit and bicker at each other
and her name is lindsey granger and she
is a conservative she's been a guest
host and she has been knocking it out of
the park over there we got to get her on
the show can we reach out to her
and she yesterday was talking to joy and
whoopi and the other oh and sunny
hosting and watch sunny sunny hosting
who's a racist and really you can just
tell she's a terrible person when i show
you this clip really watch sunny hustle
the way she looks at lindsey granger the
whole purpose of the view was that we
were going to get different women this
is what barbara walters always said
we're going to get different women from
different views to sit and respectfully
talk and that's what the show did for a
long time i want you to really look at
the way sunny hosting looks at lindsey
granger for having a different point of
view but lindsey granger's main point
here is that focusing on january 6 is a
losing message for the democrats she's
trying to tell the democrats hey do a
little bit better and just watch the way
they respond to her i think the average
fox news viewer has been seeing for a
year and a half this play out over and
over again rioters attack our capital
we've seen it on every single channel
even fox local if you watch that so
people understand exactly what happened
and so what is the smoking gun here what
is the breaking news i know what we're
waiting for people will turn in once the
department of justice says okay here are
the charges well i have to wait wait
wait wait wait let me finish we want
some criminal charges if that's what you
want that's what we'll see next we're
not even going to see that in these nine
hearings and then if we think about the
actual intention of this there's a
sentiment that democrats need to rebrand
this midterm message right so by airing
this you're going to remind everybody
like hey trump is aligned with other
conservatives and even though that's not
always true there's plenty of people who
spoke out against this and so now
reminder don't vote for these people in
the midterms because you want to keep
the majority and i think that that is a
losing message by looking in the past
and not looking in the future because
there's things on top of mind for people
there are things like feeding your baby
which i talked about yesterday there are
things on top of mine like people wanted
to know a recession is looming there are
things on top of mine like wondering how
to pay for your gas
refreshing hearing people tell the truth
i mean this is a conservative woman
sitting with four or five liberals uh
and the way that sunny hosted that face
that sunny hostin face
like what how condescending
how like what is the purpose what is the
purpose of sitting at a table every day
with other people with other views if
you're if when someone says something
you don't like that is your reaction to
it right and everything
that lindsay said there not only was
true she's tipping off she's tipping
these people up hey guys your message of
focusing on january 6 nobody really
cares about it and i love when she says
what's the smoking gun and joyce says i
don't know we'll we should basically
he's like i don't know we'll find out
that's what we're looking for it's like
if we don't know the freaking smoking
gun a year and a half into this nonsense
there ain't no smoking gun just like
there were no guns brought by any of the
protesters on january 6.